I'm Ovey Ovey Golan form a yahoo I'm a
research engineer over there and today
I'm going to share a very simple but
practical advice when it comes to
averaging so this talk will be an intro
to basic analysis applied to churn
analysis so let's start with the
definition in the first notion that
we're going to introduce is dwell time
the well time is basically the amount of
time a user spends on our property
before he or she decides to adjourn so
the the example that we are going to
follow throughout this presentation is
the amount of time a user spends on a
website before hitting the back button
other applications are how effective our
promotion codes I give a promotion code
to a customer how long is it going to
tell me my customer okay so our public
set our public settings either is the
such all we have is a list of websites
and for each for each website a list of
all the users who visited or visited it
and the amount of time they stayed we
don't have any data about the web sites
other than its address we don't know if
it's a gaming website in use or whatever
we don't know nothing about the users so
we can do any better matching so
basically the data is as simple as that
an array of websites with a list of
dwell times and giving this data we are
required to predict how long will a new
user visiting for example site 3 how
long will stay in our website so giving
this kind of pool data there isn't a lot
of things we can do I think that the
state the straightforward approach that
everyone is going to take is basically
average there the dwell times of other
users visit
same site just a moment above the
limitations so the eye is the 12-time of
user I in our website with Apple website
s and es is basically our best
prediction which is the expectancy how
long do we expect the user to stay now I
think we can all agree that this is a
good prediction when n is large we also
have a very nice theorem the central
limit theorem that guarantees that it's
going to be as accurate as possible as n
grows however what do we do when n is
small so this is a crucial point that I
at our analysis and we need to introduce
a bias so this is basically basically
two ways you can go either you're going
to say if I have less than 30
observation I have nothing to do and
give up I will try to include some prior
knowledge so here we introduced pile
knowledge in the form of pretend
visitors for example B is our bias we
can try and calculate the overall dwell
time across all other websites of any
other a bias that we want and M is the
mass of device for example I imagine
that we saw em users who stayed on the
website for B timing so with this
assumption I can apply the previous
solution without any problem just
average them out so you might have not
noticed but this is a Bayesian model we
actually introduced assumptions we
introduced prior knowledge and with this
assumption actually went to the Bayesian
side and what are the assumptions that
we made I'm not going to prove it
formally because we have only 10 minutes
and also nothing that important
basically we assumed that the
distribution with dwell times
is a Gaussian if you want some intuition
as to why is that you can assume that
basically the overall assumption is
going to look around be on the bias and
basically it's going to be as well as
our mess is so why assume Gaussian
actually everyone who dealt with Chen
analysis knows that actually the more
the more time passed more user more less
and less use of the we have good state
more uhm so this is a classical generate
decay and it looks kind of an
exponential decay for me from where I'm
doing
so let's write model it as an
exponential decay so this is the
exponential distribution we have a
parameter lambda and what we try to fit
is the best lambda that would fit our
data so with Python there's a very nice
a library that I'm not going to talk to
me that much on because Ashlyn was gonna
have a full talk on by MC well this is
kind of a teaser so with three lines of
Python what we have here is a model that
numerically and analyzes given my
assumption of a 12-time which is
exponential and I assume that the clamp
that is so before is Gaussian
distributed around our bias and our mess
this is where I'm going to cheat and
kind of rush over the details
why should I assume that lambda is
distributed as as a normal distribution
if I'm going to assume that it is
distributed as a gamma distribution then
basically all the math work out and
we're going to have a beautiful formula
at the end of the presentation so if the
formulas work out basically this is not
a formal definition by no means then we
call the distribution a conjugate pile
okay so given gamma did have two
parameters alpha and beta I choose alpha
and beta the head--it have the mean that
they want for example both again rushing
to the formulas Montana I'm cheating a
bit and at the end I know that the
distribution given the assumption of
exponential exponential likelihood and
gamma a posterior is going to look like
that with me which means the initial
alpha and the amount of twelve times
that I have and the denominator better
and some of divided sum of 1 over the
dwell times if I replace the parameters
as alpha is now called M and beta is now
called
M divided by B whoa I get this formula
maybe this rings a bell for those of you
I have some experience in physics this
is called the harmonic mean the harmonic
mean basically pops his head when
averaging speeds or decay rates for
example if I traveled here if the way
him 100 miles per hour and the other
half in 50 miles per hour my average
speed is not 75 miles per hour it's
actually 66 F of the widest and wise
distance wise okay so this is what what
I expect most of you to take from these
lectures is not the gamma distribution
and exponential function and what have
you
adjustment when you analyze data first
try to plot it if it looks centralized
then basically the straightforward mean
should be good enough for you but if it
looks like an exponential decay may be
the harmonic mean is a better fit so
that's it
hey everyone I'm glad I woke the devil
compliant
originally from a vendor on University
I'm going to talk about how to visualize
neural networks yeah yeah okay so start
with this okay so why do it how many of
you by the way I will train the neural
network okay using curvas ok still ok so
so if you haven't done that
yeah probably wondered after 20
networked is it good is it converging
should I just keep convert it more would
be better
Oh when does it enough what classes
conflict with others I mean if I'm
looking at image domain some photos look
similar to others just like they get of
six it's similar to zero can I tell
which classes conflicts with others
after the network just by visualizing
the network and what kind of features
are meaningful if I have a very
meaningful features it's okay but maybe
I have a leakage in the data and they
have some kind of label that it's inside
the terrain and and - I saw it happened
to me once is when training a classifier
for autism I forgot to add some part of
the features for the control group so I
build any one network I got close to one
accuracy but when you visualize the data
you see that when they when there is no
feature that possible data it goes one
way and if there are features you go the
other way so how can you tell that
beforehand so I'm going to introduce
some kind of
future which L to us the use case for
the story would be the enemies data I
hope that you all familiar with it it's
actually a photo of the bigoted to the
actual bigot
so for this we're going to build a very
simple neural network model the first
layer will be the input layer which will
get photo at a time second layer will be
a convolution 3x3 and then we're going
to use pooling is this Chinese Oh
everyone with me okay so polling is
basically four dimensionality reduction
inside the network after the convolution
afterwards we're going to connect it to
a full length to a dense layer fully
connected Network
newald a layer and do a softmax at the
end so we can get the actual prediction
so in this case if I'm going to put five
as the input the softmax the source map
layer the new one that corresponds to
the number of five bigoted should beat
up you should get one value while the
other and new ones should get to zero
okay so and the last thing that we're
going to do given this model is to try
to visualize the layer before the last
oh how it's walking first you to any
model then you create a copy of the
model you do it without the last layer
you don't want the softmax layer because
it does some kind of calculation that
enhance the upper values and decrease
the law of us so we end up with a vector
which ever one in one new one and zero
in the rest you don't want that for the
visualization and you want a data set
through the mock model you get
activation to the layer that you want
and you can do a PCA or whatever we want
on the activations it's kind of transfer
learning and with a PCA at the end
can use it for other class offenses
where afterwards okay so we had the
model before what you're going to do is
to put the to predict a huge data set of
a list and instead of using the last
soft max layer we're going to take the
activations out of the layer before the
last and some code so you can see on the
left is the model that I just described
there's an input layer and the
convolution max pool and dense layer
afterwards what I'm going to do is just
build on the right here another model
which is similar to the first one I'm
going to use the actual layer that I
used on the first one so we can see here
when I adding the first layer I'm
getting the layer the input layer from
the last model so I'm building the
entire model other than the last layer
then you can get some nice visualization
so this is a missed data this is the
test at ten thousand digits that's
before the network was even trained so
you can see it's kind of random and
there is some kind of structure in the
data so we can imagine that the blue
dots are separated from the other and
red dots on the left but it's not an
actual structure so when you go after
five epochs you can start and see some
structure and after 20 pox you can
actually build a classifier on this
that's it
great alright so again my name is Todd
Perry I work at Citibank I do way I know
to work with deep learning but there
they decided my projects to confidential
to present it here so as I said I'm
gonna tell you click and why we might
want to use the recurrent neural network
and then I'll tell you really quickly
what it is and then I'll show you some
cool tricks that we can do to make them
work better or these faster
look yeah so why do we want to use our
names click okay so this is like how I
feel all the time I wanna do awesome
data signs I want to figure out what my
girlfriend's gonna go crazy and how do I
should cook a chicken and do stuff at
work but I need to do future engineer
engineering for that and that sucks cuz
its harm quick thank you
so let's look it like the old way of
doing things before deep learning right
so here's a the Sobel operator which can
take a picture and kind of give us up
lines and then we get this and maybe
with these outlines we can figure out
something about the image right and
someone very smart figured out that if I
take this matrix and clean all the image
and I think this ensures in a control
image I'll get this and what do i do I
don't know all right but that's doesn't
help me much
but instead now with deep learning and
the framework so we can see a dumb
engineer who doesn't understand it like
me and just go back all right and just
write these lines of code and what we'll
get is basically this right we'll input
an image the first layer in the network
is going to learn these basic features
and the next layer in the network is
going to learn this basic feature these
more advanced features and so on and so
on and what the network's we're doing is
kind of learning these in this case
right it's learning these matrices by
itself it's figuring out how to extract
features so it's doing the future
engineering for me I just need to tell
it I guess the architecture right and
it'll do the hard work for me quick ok
so the thing is that my data I like what
I work with really is chat and my date
is sequential and I want to make
sequential predictions but the tools
that I just described they don't work so
great for sequences have to wait ok so
some examples of sequential data that we
might encounter - speech recognition
a lot of great successes this year with
it translation Google's new a neural
machine translation autocomplete so
here's a great example of shitty
autocomplete sequential data right he
wrote something and you need to predict
the export and it was supposed to be
there but the Machine predicted dead
so that's crappy and or maybe the stock
market right we all want to predict
what's gonna happen tomorrow and make
sense of money and for our Hebrew
friends this is a project that they want
say to add it and he could die
accreditation marks two texts over you
have similar not be good and you want to
add it so sequential problems next okay
and the thing is we've sequences write
sequences can be really short they can
be really long and in longer sequences
we have like dependencies over time at
different levels so what was the
previous word but what do we say two
sentences to paragraphs ago and we
somehow want to capture that but okay so
here's a really really cool example of
our n ends in action that kind of
illustrates long term dependencies so I
stole it from the co potty his amazing
blog post you don't know I'm he's like
the ron jeremy of deep learning and i
love everyone who got that joke okay
great so what he well look what he did
basically was he built a model he
defeated character by character attacks
he cited the linux source code and what
he asked the models to do was to predict
what's the next character going to beach
and after he trained the model then he
took them out of game to character it
predicted something put that prediction
back in had give another output etc etc
and what the model came out with was you
know stuff that looks like the linux
source code so that's pretty cool but we
could have done that ago with hidden
Markov models or other crs but what's
awesome of this and kind of special is
that it captures these long-term
dependency right so if you notice it
opens an indentation after the function
declaration and then i see if it opens
another one and it knows how to close it
and if this is it kind of remembers
where i'm invented which is something
that I this aren't I'm not familiar with
other models that are good at capturing
this so that's kind of the amazing power
of it
recurrent neural networks we got so far
understand one thing but using
so next click okay so what is an R in it
now that we saw like how awesome the
kinder we have those off and okay so
this is basically the code for an RN for
the forward step the part that makes it
predict not the part that makes it there
so basically the RN n has three kind of
transition matrixes you can think about
it and the hidden state this thing H
right and at every step we give the iron
in an input like X and basically we
update the hidden step the hidden state
by taking the product of the state
transition matrix you could call it for
the hidden state with what it was and
also adding something from the input so
basically our new state is some sort of
combination of this state we had before
and the input we just got and once we
updated our state we're gonna and apply
it to that we're gonna apply them yeah
we're not use our new transition matrix
and the new state to get an up and
that's pretty much what RN does then
working with it
is just kind of iterating over the
inputs with that thing again making now
why is this so great you didn't get that
completely and apologize and if you
think about like a regular model if we
won the sequence we needed a parameter
or some way to input something for every
step in the sequence so it means we need
a lot of parameters and it means that we
can't really grow arbitrarily two
different sequences but the medium of
the our intent is that the only
parameters it has it used to learn is
this hit is the matrix in the hidden
state and then we recycle that we use it
every step every step so instead of
having parameters that grow linearly
with the size of the input
we're constant in the term the number of
parameters we need wilfer Garcia which
means that we can do arbitrary steps
they're arbitrary sequences that's a
great success okay so one of the things
we want with that we want this kind of
more of a memory thing the reason is
that Arden's behave poorly mathematical
exactly go into it so some really smart
people invented Alice jams which is
instead of having that one H that we saw
there you get this thing these are the
equations that they find it we won't
jump into them it takes 15 minutes to
learn them and to to forget click and
basically what it does is it kind of has
this thing all right this is I saw an
input and this is what I'm going to take
from it and that's not an input so I
should forget some stuff right that's
what the cell does so if we go back to
the car body example then he kind of
sees okay I saw a bracket of bracket
bracelet whatever right so I should
remember this I sure didn't then and he
sees another one I should remember this
I treated men and then I don't know at
the end of this if block is like okay I
just finished the if block without a
bracket I should I mean the next one and
when it gets here to the bouquet I
should onion Bangladesh forget my
invitation and that's what the Ellis
campus okay go okay so we've covered
what are our dens and what are other
stands and now some tips and tricks okay
so let's get one more okay so in my work
I'm doing entity recognition I'm a
sequences right so looking at a lot of
chat and basically we label all the
sequences ahead of time so mostly stocks
and then we want our intent of the
network to be able to recognize them
according to the content of a appearing
so for example we might have a chat that
looks like you have any poop that
foreign active fruits for bonds over
four and a half pay interest rate that
expires in 2020 that's what this thing
says right and we want the our intent to
be able to recognize that this is a
ticker this is an entity but we don't
want it to memorize it
so one of the cool tricks that we did
was to every time we saw this the
training set
we're just converted into something
random some random jump and the next
time we saw goo we also convert to
something random but else so what
happens is that the network every time
it encounters a ticker
it gets no information from the actual
letters in the ticker it has nothing to
learn there and so it has to learn only
from the context and then what we notice
is that we get these really nice things
that it realizes all right if I have a
rate in the maturity which entities in
our world then the thing that precedes
it must be a ticker but we didn't tell
it that it didn't
to learn those rules and then we found
that it can it can tell the difference
between things that are kind of a gymnic
that can be a ticker or a country like
Russia could be a bazan could be a place
depending on what song they wrote that
one okay so last trick and so in the
wonderful Bible the deep learning book
right one of the things they say is that
the learning rate is perhaps the most
important hyper hyper parameters if you
only have one hyper wrap around Goethe
to work on that one further you don't
know the learning rate Bisping deep
learning general learning we kind of a
we make a prediction and we look at the
gradient that we get from the error
right and we try and correct the point
that the gradient kind of gives us
information learning where it says how
much of the information am I going to
update right how about you I trust it
kind of and one of the things that
really helps with training at Network is
kind of the king then at the learning
rate over time so sometimes I'll start
with a High Line and I'll have it
slowly-slowly thinking now what I
noticed in my work is that it's really
nice to start with a really aggressive
learning rate like happy and but if I
keep on going with half after two
hundred three hundred steps then I stop
learning I'm kind of screwed and if I
wait for exponential decay to kick in
then I either go very fast as your own
or nothing all right not really moving
and I spend the day waiting for for it
to go low enough to get back to them so
tensorflow
gives us two really nice things to
conquer this okay so why is it gives us
kind of a way to make an exponential
decay of our learning right I needed a
global step and we visit the global step
all right where we are now in kind of
the kid gloating where you automatically
but that's too slow so the other thing
you've given us is the one on top this
piecewise constant or you can say all
right for the first hundred steps
give me a learning rate of half and then
from one hundred to five hundred giving
me Oh point zero five but five times
roots one thousand give me 0.005 which
is great because then I can start really
aggressive drop really quickly drop
really but what I want is the but is
both I want to drop really quickly in
the beginning and then go to a smooth
exponential decay afterwards so we can
use tensor flows condition right it has
this opera
we can say all right yes the global step
is less than a thousand then use the
piecewise operator that I didn't kind of
stay these higher high learning rates
then jump down but if we passed a
thousand then I start using the
exponential decay and then you can get
the best of both worlds
finish often the work I've been doing
this has really made life much easier
faster and more effective I highly
recommend it thank you as a forecasting
manager for Strauss for a JV of Strauss
and PepsiCo and we produce snacks
probably all of you are familiar with
taco chips Doritos Cheetos and for the
past three years or so I've been
tackling many challenges at Kegel and I
think that most of my experience in the
data science and machine learning comes
from there
and my talk is gonna be on validation
methods and this is a map of my talk
we're gonna discuss why do we need
validation the basics of validation and
some more advanced things like
validation on group data time serious
and unbalanced data I assume that most
of you are familiar with the basics but
we'll go through them anyhow ok so why
do we need validation so validation is
is used to fit our training data as well
as we as well as we can but on the same
time we would like to generalize so we
don't just memorize the training data
but we can also predict on unseen data
what we call the refrain from
overfitting and we use validation on
selecting the best model we also use it
to select the best hyper parameters and
on early stopping decision
in the graph here we can see that we
have a training score which deteriorates
because we use bridge which uses a with
sorry we use reach which is a regular
eyes model and therefore our training
score deteriorates but our cross body
validated score increases okay so the
basics of validation so the very basic
model for validation is just to keep
some of our training data as a holdout
sample what we can see here is just
randomize the sample and we can examine
our mod the model that we trained on the
holdout sample and test our performance
on what is unseen for the model so while
train test split validation is very
common
its main benefits are computational
efficiency and simplicity but it has two
disadvantages for first we're losing
large amount of data in order to get
robust results on our validation we have
to set aside enough data and if we set
aside a large amount of data so we're
not using it in order to learn and this
is a big disadvantage especially on
small data data sets and we might suffer
from skewness and bias the solution that
we have for for losing data is using
cross-validation we can split our data
into pieces I assume most of you know
this suppose we have five folds so we
can use each
one of the folds for validation it's one
each one of the pieces that we set aside
as validation for one iteration of
training and we can average the score
the scores of all of them in order to
get a more robust validation score that
will tell us better what is going to be
our actual score the solution that we
have for skewness or bias depends on
whether we're doing regression or
classification is using static
stratification suppose we have a target
variable that is either 0 or 1 but we
don't have but we don't have equal
proportions of them or one of them is a
sparse so we can have the same
proportion of each of them in each of in
each one of the folds is that clear
great so what happens if our data is
grouped if we have some sort of group
that characterizes our our data so the
first question that we have to ask
ourself is can we retrain each time we
we are getting a new group if the answer
is yes so we can you keep on using
either k-fold or stratified k-fold but
if the answer is no then we have to use
grouped based folding methods which
means that we have to set aside a group
or a number of groups in order for our
model to be robust to newly newly
presented data so an example for
retraining is signature each of us when
we go to open an account in a bank we
are asked to give several signatures
in order for the machine learning there
to to learn our signature and our
signature style and they can retrain the
model for our signature but another
example for unseen or or data without
the ability to retrain what I put here
is the example for from the state our
state farm competition we can see that
this was a classification problem that
the target was to classify whether or
not the driver is distracted and if he
is distracted by what way is it
distracted like is he look into the
passenger looking behind texting or
talking on the phone or maybe drinking
so as we can see this driver and this
word driver are the same driver and the
rest of them are different drivers but
if we have this one in in our training
and this one in our validation our
validation result will not be
representative to our true result when
we will meet a new driver but if we can
set aside one driver or a group of
drivers so our validation method will be
more robust so the last thing I want to
talk about is time series data and time
series data we have different type of
questions that we should be asking
ourselves are we predicting for a
specific time frame like are we
predicting for August which
characterized by a high number of
vacations or things like that so maybe
our validation period should be for
August the previous year or something
like that are we predicting for only
future events or also for the past event
and if we're predicting for future
events then we have to set either
sliding window or encodes like sliding
window so that we only capture the
meaning of future events and not the and
not for past events we have to we have
to remember that if we use just random
sampling it's more like an imputation
problem rather than a true prediction
and I think that's about it
thank you any of you has any questions
about validation Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm going to talk about wow that's
awesome
you know the first rule of deep learning
is don't talk about deep learning so I'm
going to do something completely
different
how did he take engagement in record
recordings okay so what course AI who
you're heard of course AI come on
seriously you're not listening we're the
sponsors so we're really cool start up
we are in Tel Aviv and San Francisco the
team in Israel is mostly development and
research so the cool stuff last week we
announced our series a so you know it's
a good place to come working and what
what does chorus do what is the chorus
nobody knows the meaning of the wording
you know Israelis so what we do is that
conversation analytics what does that
means so we automatically record sales
goals we help find and sure things in
your calls that matter and I have a tip
for you data scientists or basically
salespeople
what you do is analyze data but this
isn't the purpose of your work you want
to help people provide them insight
understand what they want to do with the
data and usually do that by talking to
them and having calls with your
customers whether they are in your
organization or out of it
so having sales skills recording your
call is going to help you do that
whether you do it with curves or just
recording it in case of sales you want
to understand the true state overton
sales opportunity you want to be able to
hand off a set opportunity to another
sales person in the organization without
explaining all of the details and you
want to become a better salesperson all
the time you become better by creating
sales pitch States the playlist with the
best practices with how to overcome
objections let's say you're selling
Bayesian data science tools and somebody
is wondering about the average so if you
have a killer answer that one person
answered once the entire team can learn
this and use it next time that they
encounter on this so we can get better
by looking at what other people in our
team did just to sum this up currently
we have millions of salespeople in the
States having a lot of meetings with
their customers in the past this data
was some kind of black box nobody knows
what happens in it and nobody can
analyze it using course you can unlock
these data we provide a lot of value
over the data which can then be utilized
by the salespeople sales manager and
data scientist in teams of those
customers so this is the course and as I
said we are going to record your sales
course now imagine you're the head of
product anyone here is the head of
product you you can be the head of
product then be a data scientist I have
news for you so imagine you are yoga
promoter right now
sure send me your CV what do customers
want your product to have you need to
know that what do they laughs so what
what's the best feature in your in your
product what do they hate what do you
need to take out what do you need to
make better and still later science is
the same thing you are basically
studying a product which is data science
so you need to be able to identify
what's working and what's not working
when you talk to your customers and when
you pitch your ass a data science
project
now I'm sure that no one here is the VP
of Sales ok yeah VP of Sales pays better
at telling you so you want to know what
do sales people say that makes people go
oh my gosh oh my gosh Wow we need that
and now I didn't find that recording
today when I was building the lecture
but people actually do say that so if
you have a feature that make people go
crazy and you can present it in a way
that makes people really relate to a
product you want to share it in your
organization you want to be able to
identify when something good happened
and when you are pitching when you are
selling you don't have the time and
energy usually to identify that you had
a really good response at a specific
moment so we're going to help you do
that
that and left me so we have a really
great moment you want to know what did
the person say that may produce this
great moment so I guess you know if you
say this is sounds easy we have an NLP
or information retrieval problem we just
need to find oh my god and awesome
or I hate it if you want to find the
negative stuff and of course course we
have a whole pipeline of conversation
analytics so we do the automatic speech
recognition we do recording we do the
NLP so our SR technology is pretty good
you could assume that you just build a
sentiment classifier look for very
positive things very negative things
do something with it you know profit so
let's try the it's also an example so so
let me play this again and we have
another type of awesome so both of them
are saying awesome I don't know if you
guys heard it yeah it's the same
language it's the same words man yeah I
think yeah I think there is having a
problem with the screen in a second
anybody here from Dell come on raise
your hands it's your fault now there are
at least six of them that I saw okay
okay now I'm here so we had the first
one though that said excited they're
awesome that's great and then we had the
other one yeah yeah that's awesome yeah
that's awesome so one of them is waiting
for the pitch to end the other really
like part of it is really liking what's
happening so we have that not awesome
awesome the tone is totally flat like
it's awesome and yeah it's also ontology
dude and fun fact I don't know people in
information studies so people can say
positive words in a tone that conveys
another meaning it could be the total
difference why you keep popping up on my
screen
so another fact this can actually be a
cue this could mean that the person
listening to your sales pitch doesn't
want to buy is just trying to let you
off easily a same yeah they're all
sounds awesome but right now we are not
going to look for this guy on of
engagement this kind of technology we're
going to go in the house so this might
actually be a very valuable cue for you
as well so how can we tell awesome
awesome apart from the lot awesome
awesome when you do speech analysis one
of the main features you work with is
speech I'm not going to explain pitch
too much but this is like the basic
currency of speech analysis and we can
extract it with open code tools to get
the frequency in these little time
slices so we can get numbers the numbers
vary between 50 usually to 250 and this
is the pitch you know this is low pitch
high pitch being different and now what
do we see here we have the two awesomes
that we have have heard before one of
them is this and the other is this
notice that it's the same person so it
even has the same shape but if you
analyze the data you can see that one of
them is very flat the standard deviation
is very low the range is small it's only
80 to 100 well this goes from 50 all the
way to 140 so if you analyze the pitch
you can build a model to identify the
difference between awesome and awesome
sorry
this was the frequency at you know it
slice like half
I don't ten milliseconds okay yeah so
just before I and you can identify using
this this is now twenty seconds
it's an utterance and you can identify
easily were the stresses so if I'm
saying awesome here it's not that
awesome but if I'm saying awesome here
it's pretty good and of course in real
life we have all sorts of pitch contours
they're not as easy there is difference
between male and females difference
between a speaker that is always using a
low pitch and every small variance is a
big deal while there are some speakers
who are all over the place and you need
to look for bigger change when you build
this model so you have to learn a
background model for the speaker for the
gender and and finally add all of this
into a learning algorithm using the text
that you get from your users when you do
things wrong in this case this is
someone complaining here they're saying
it was a total [ __ ] show and then they
continue to complain it's actually not
relevant to anything about their
speaking about is complaining about uber
not being able to bring him to his
meeting on time I'm not going to play it
because it would take me two minutes
thank you all for listening chorus as I
said we're hiring look us up
[Applause]